[Applaudissements]
j'invite en clair l'auteur des photos
paraissent à l'arrêt l'avoir vu comme un
démon et ps4 la juste motta faut juste
faire le lever on vous avez vu dans
celle ci il l'a vu à tous les âges
je suis pas le plus léger de la bande à
eddie et donc il va le porter non melzer
qu'il en soit voilà oui c'est ça
regardez vous avez vu c'est comme ça
qu'ils battent elles courent caouette on
fait gaffe quand même parce qu'on perd
pas on en a besoin
attention et puis la balle au dos
regardez la pluie
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
parce qu'on n'a pas de la plus mauvaise
attaque ça c'est parti à l'essai motards
on les appelle garde cohen 24 et bogota
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]